hey luke here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel today we're doing
camping meals i'm going to walk you
through breakfast lunch dinner we're
doing it all about 20 recipes from the
very very simple to something a little
bit more challenging but all of this is
stuff that's pretty practical that
doesn't require specialty equipment and
that's really easy to do whether you're
backpacking or car camping we're going
to cover it all now if you want to see a
little bit fancier campfire cooking i've
got a lot of videos on that whether it's
making my own bread from scratch or beef
bone stew
so check the link down below for those
types of videos
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
costa rican casato is just amazing it
can be as gourmet or as simple as you
like just based on which ingredients you
use it is amazing
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well there you go steamed muffin it's
about as easy as making cereal super
tasty and all you got to pack into the
woods is a packet of powder
[Music]
well other than the little brown spots
that you have here and there it tastes
exactly like a hard-boiled egg
just you did it in the fire rash
[Music]
is that pretty easy you think you could
do that yourself
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's good
oh i've already eaten so much food
tonight
if getting up early in the morning to
cook an elaborate meal doesn't sound
appealing to you try making breakfast
from last night's leftovers and one of
my favorites is breakfast rice
[Music]
[Music]
oh
if you like oatmeal or rice pudding this
is going to be right up your alley
[Music]
all right right behind the dipstick
seems to be the hot spot i think we give
it about 10-15 miles and it should be
perfectly cooked
30 minutes of cooking time
let's
[Music]
want a hot dog
here guys you who wants a hot dog there
you go bud
you guys want s'mores
i can't have it on the s'more
all right we got the s'mores sitting on
the engine block we'll let that sit for
about 10 minutes
s'more
there you go not a bad engine block
s'more
[Music]
[Music]
looks like
[Music]
oh
[Music]
sweet and savory and it warms you to the
bones which is great on a cold rainy day
like today
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[ __ ]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
now
those look pretty good to tommy
oh okay i have that one sure
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
that is so delicious that italian
sausage just absolutely makes it amazing
the seasonings are perfect
[Music]
well there you go nice little omelette
all you need is some fire something to
boil water in
all right most of these recipes are
things that i really love to eat but
here's one that's more about convenience
than flavor and it's one that was a
staple of camping when i was growing up
get yourself a thing of instant top
ramen
pull it out of the package
put the seasoning on there
and enjoy
you won't get any michelin stars for
making this but it's cheap it's easy
and it will fill you up
[Music]
[Music]
oh eating steak and vegetables while
camping may sound a bit luxurious but
it's super simple requires very little
utensils or cookware and it's
surprisingly cheap the steak was about
six dollars the vegetables about four
for ten dollars two hungry adults can
eat steak and vegetables this is a lot
of food
[Music]
i love these heat and serve indian curry
packets they're two to three bucks they
have a shelf life of about a year and a
half the serving sizes are generous and
they have every flavor and type of curry
under the rainbow that you can choose
from sometimes when you're camping you
just gotta resist the urge to overthink
it
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ah
see i can't stop eating it oh sausage
gravy is so good
another simple but wonderful way to use
last night's leftovers is french toast
[Music]
um
wow
[Music]
you haven't had french toast until
you've had it cooked over an open fire
in a pool of hot butter with big chunks
of artisan bread absolutely delicious
and a great way to use leftovers you
want some work
oh yeah
that's good
i love this shop
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
now that right there is a perfect
breakfast sandwich
yolk dripping right out of there whoa
the butter and the frying pan just makes
the toast so much better
smoke oh just everything everything
about this is delicious
here in the u.s we're so used to eating
that highly processed instant oatmeal
it's easy to forget how delicious and
filling real oatmeal can be
so next time you're on a camp out take a
little extra effort make yourself some
real oatmeal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are good
super easy and loads of fun to do
biscuits and gravy man gotta love it
[Music]
[Music]
uh
foreign
if i'm not going to drag a lot of
utensils into the woods this is one of
my absolutely favorite meals
if you don't want to go through the
hassle of making your own biscuits just
bring a loaf of bread or some dinner
rolls with you make the gravy from the
packet and just dip it in that still
pretty darn good
you can get the little individual
serving size frito package and just make
the tacos right inside the package super
simple
[Music]
okay watch out
[Music]
oh
[Music]
isn't that absolutely gorgeous
beautiful fresh caught fish and chips on
the bank of a river i got some malt
vinegar here that i'm going to put on it
[Music]
that was good
[Applause]
[Music]
if you ever get tired of top ramen and
cup of noodle and want to mix it up a
little bit try these instant yaki soba
meals really cheap and they come in a
bajillion different flavors
oh this one's spicy well i hope you guys
enjoyed this video because i think i
just put on 20 pounds
if you want to see other videos like
this we did a great video with my top
campfire snacks put a link in the
description and don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning thanks for watching if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]